all that chaos on capitol hill is just
the latest crisis facing the bight
administration now joe's record of
failure is starting to catch up with him
in the polls not only is he underwater
on approval in the latest pew research
poll but a majority by the way of uh
respondents 56 percent yeah they think
joe biden is not mentally sharp and by
the way i don't know who this other 40
percent are or what you're thinking and
by the way the vaccine mandates that
biden is so eager to impose on everyone
they could soon be having disastrous
consequences for the democrats look at
new york state for example they're
preparing to actually call up the
national guard to fill in for hospital
workers you know the ones in march and
april and may of 2020
in the middle of the covet shift show of
all shift shows yeah
they're thinking of firing them many
that got coveted that jumped on covet
grenades every day to save the lives of
their fellow citizens yeah they're all
about to be fired
for refusing to get the vaccine sounds
like biden could have yet another crisis
of his own making on his hands before he
even knows it here with the reaction
author of beyond biden rebuilding the
america we love i can hope and pray
uh well written book i have my my copy
thank you mr speaker fox news
contributor news newt gingrich
all right we got to get beyond biden
it's never been this bad we never
abandoned americans we never begged opec
from to produce more oil uh giving up
energy independence you see the mess at
the border you see inflation my question
is
uh you see this fight going on with the
squad versus so-called moderates who
wins
well i think the country loses
uh and i think first of all
with very few exceptions maybe mansion
and cinema
there aren't any real moderates in the
democratic party when push came to shove
in august
every single democrat in the senate
every single democrat in the house
voted for a big socialist bill that big
government socialist bill that bernie
sanders wrote i mean how can you have a
clearer message
than to have an open socialist write a
bill which by the way probably scores at
five trillion not three and a half
trillion has three trillion dollars in
tax increases
hires 85 000
new irs agents to harass taxpayers uh
apparently according to one reading
provides for free community college for
illegal immigrants so all these people
at the border will get to go to college
at the taxpayers expense because
nothing's free that means it's a
taxpayer provided college it's a
taxpayer provided health care uh and so
i think that uh this is going to be a
fascinating week uh pelosi's been very
tough she runs a dictatorship
she's been twisting arms she's now
starting to break them uh presently
she'll start kneecapping people and
whether or not that's enough but it
seems like the squad is basically saying
it's our way of the highway
and they have control over her
speakership
well they only do in the sense that they
have enough votes that she probably
can't pass a purely democratic bill
without their votes but but look what
they've done for the last year
they've decided everything by themselves
in fact they even reached over and
kicked a republican off a committee
something which had never been done
before they created an investigating
committee and they controlled republican
appointees so now they turn it's like
it's like having somebody if your
teenage son or daughter had run off with
a credit card ran around and charged
everything bought a ferrari uh
bought you know round-trip airline
tickets stayed at five-star hotels then
showed up one morning and said gee dad
why don't you pay all of my bills
and that's where the republicans are now
saying no
we're not part of this we weren't in on
the takeoff we're not going to be on the
landing and the democrats have made no
effort to reach out to the republicans
and actually try to share power so i
would raise my questions to the house
and senate be calm and see what happens
i don't think any republicans should
vote to increase the debt ceiling they
have the house they have the senate
right they want to spend all this money
republicans don't that there is no
opportunity to work with a republican i
don't think one republican should vote
to increase it by a penny now democrats
are going to say oh you're going to shut
down the government and the full faith
and credit of the u.s government is
going to be at stake that's not true
they have control of congress they have
control of the purse strings they get to
decide so it'll be up to them whether or
not they raise the debt ceiling correct
yeah i mean you know if if i were the
republican leadership i'd say look you
can get our votes
uh drop the five trillion dollar
spending bill drop the three trillion
dollar tax increase drop the idea of 85
000 new irs agents you know you want to
talk about us helping you well this is
what it's going to cost for us to decide
to help you and if you don't want us if
you don't want to meet us and negotiate
why would we give you our votes i mean
no republican should vote for the debt
ceiling increase that's the democrats
problem it is their disaster
and frankly if they keep putting poison
pills into the continuing resolution
no republicans should vote for the
continuing resolution so
very careful
you have a great
pulse of how things are working in dc it
seems like democrats the civil war is
going on so what happens in the house
will mansion and cinema hold the line
because i think ultimately their arms
are going to get twisted so hard they'll
probably rip them out of the socket to
get their votes
well i think they have a hard time doing
that they're offering a bill which will
destroy
west virginia's economy totally they're
offering some ideas which are deeply
opposed in
arizona remember
big government socialism only has about
16 support one out of every six
americans now it may be
that the lemming is replacing the donkey
as the democratic party symbol and they
may all be about to run off a cliff
together but i think this is going to be
very unpopular in the country and my
guess is they're not going to get it
through because in the end they can't
satisfy those who aren't moderates but
they want to survive
and those who are radicals in districts
where it doesn't matter i think it's an
almost impossible job for pelosi
did you ever think it'd get this radical
ever think we'd abandon americans across
enemy lines do you ever think we'd have
that kind of chaos at the border do you
ever think that we'd be begging opec
after we finally achieved energy
independence for to produce more oil and
they turn us down
pretty embarrassing mr
speaker look i think you're faced with
uh the weirdest
political coalition in modern american
history i think that they are totally
out of touch with reality i think the
damage they're doing is unimaginable and
i really worry that these guys could
stumble into a big war not a small war
and i worry particularly about china
because the chinese dictatorship has to
be looking at this chaos and just
thinking this guy's old he's weak he's
confused it makes sense
he makes those donald trump tweets that
everyone in the mob and the media
characterized as mean seem pretty
appealing actually about right now
because he actually
he instilled fear in other countries and
he actually got us to energy
independence controlled the borders
lowered taxes and things work better
uh mr speaker thank you hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else